Welcome to Project Pannonia, a collaboration
involving 11 History YouTubers all doing videos
on various events in the History of the Pannonian
basin.
From the Roman era all the way to Hungary's
involvement in WW2.
And what better way to start off this colab
then with the people that created the province
that gave these grasslands the name of Pannonia,
the Romans.
Prior to the Roman conquest of Pannonia, we
don’t really know much about the area or
the people living in it.
However looking through archeology and “very”
brief mentions of the area in Latin and Greek
sources we can gather small clues as to what
happened.
At the beginning of the 4th century BCE there
was a big Celtic invasion of Pannonia which
coincided with the Celtic invasion of Italy.
This invasion was mostly centered around going
down the Danube and Drava rivers.
The people that inhabited the area before
the Celts were mostly the illyrian tribe of
Pannonii.
When they got pushed out by the Celts this
tribe moved south settling around the Sava
river.
However despite this resettlement in the 3rd
century BCE the Pannonii eventually succumbed
to a celtic invasion by a tribe called Scordisci.
During this time eastern Panonnia and Transilvania
was mostly controlled by the Dacians a subgroup
of Threcians but that didn’t stop the Celts
migrating there as well.
For the next couple of centuries the Pannonian
area underwent large celticization with the
Dacian lands having mixed Dacian/Celtic culture
and the Scordisci controlled Pannonii having
a mixed Illirian/Celitc culture.
However even though the entire area was under
the celtic influence, this is not to say it
was all unified.
There where many bickering celtic tribes that
didn’t seem to be the best of friends.
Some of the most notable ones where the Boii
tribal alliance who were driven out of northern
Italy by the Romans in 193 and settled in
Northern Pannonia, the Taurisci inhabiting
western Pannonia, the Scordisci around the
Sava river, and of course the celtic Dacians
in Eastern Pannonia and Transilvania.
In around 88 to 81 BCE the Scordisci which
were struggling to keep control over the Pannonii
for several decades now where decisively defeated
by a Roman general Lucius Cornelius Scipio
Asiaticus, no not that one, his grade grandson,
yeah that one.
How unimaginative where the romans, It is
a freaking 4 part name and yet there still
manages to be two of them with the exact same
name, But I digress.
After this defeat the Scordisci disappear
being replaced by their captives the Pannonii.
Also starting during this time until around
45 BCE the Thracian king Burebista solidified
the dacian lands and conquered all of pannonia
east of the Danube.
This Dacian pressure from the East, newly
liberated Illirian pressure from the South
and Roman pressure from the west destroyed
the larger celtic political entities that
existed up until now and the celtic control
of Pannonia became very fragmented.
When exactly the basin became part of the
Roman empire is very much debated, but most
likely due to the now fragmented political
nature of the area it was a gradual process
done under the reign of Agustus from around
35 to 9 BCE.
It was also during this time that the Dacian
control of Eastern pannonia slowly withered
away as the kingdom struggled to keep together
after the death of Burebista.
In 11 BCE the frontier of the Roman Empire
was officially set all the way to the Danube
river and then 2 years later this new land
was incorporated to the provinc of Illiricum.
However certain areas of this frontier weren’t
very loyal to the Empire and the Romans didn’t
really have any major control in the countryside.
This along with the local resentment against
the Romans resulted in the Great Illirian
revolt in 6 CE.
However this mainly involved just the Illirians
in southern Pannonia as the Celts further
north seemed to have been content with the
Roman rule.
When the revolt was finally subdued by Tiberius
and Germanicus three years later, illiricum
was deemed to be too large to govern effectively
and so it was divided up.
One of these newly created provincies was
the province of Pannonia.
It was also in the early 1st century that
the Sarmantian tribe of Iazyges migrated in
to the area east of the Danube.
Whether the Romans invited them to come here
and act as a buffer between them and the Dacians
or they migrated on their own using the fracturing
of the Dacian kingdom to their benefit, is
still debated.
What’s also debated is the origin of the
name Pannonia but in my opinion it most likely
comes from an Illirian word which meant swampy
land or wetland, which makes since as the
pannonian basin is just a giant tributary
for the Danubian river and Illirians were
the original inhabitants of this area.
Now Roman Pannonia didn’t stretch across
the entire pannonian basin, it encompassed
only the areas of the basin West and South
of the Danube.
However with that said this Roman province
name started to be used to refer to the entire
geographical location of the basin in the
medieval period, hence why we call this entire
area the Pannonian Basin or plain today.
When it came to administrative matters Pannonia
actually underwent several changes throughout
the Roman period.
First being the province of Pannonia then
dividing in to two Pannonias then in to four
then back again in to one, etc.
However I am going to be mostly skipping over
these divisions referring to Pannonia as a
whole.
So from the year 9 at the end of the Illirian
revolt Pannonia was finally firmly under Roman
control and it will stay like this until the
5th century.
To put this in to perspective, Romans controlled
Pannonia for longer than USA has been a country
plus about 200 years more.
With this much time of Roman rule in the area
it is undeniable that they left their mark
on these lands.
The first major change that came with the
Romans was the creation of cities.
Yes there where population establishments
like celtic oppidums before the Roman arrival
but the majority of these were more of a “fortified
village” rather than an actual city.
However as Roman colonists arrived combined
with the slow latinization of the native population,
Pannonia gradually became more urbanized.
This urbanization was also helped in part
by the creation of the Roman road network
which the Romans build mainly for an ease
of supply to the legions stationed in Pannonia.
Along with building up these major roads and
cities, 3 of which are capital cities today
the Romans also did some engineering work
on the Danube.
This is because some parts of the Danube back
then where very treacherous for boats and
sailing on it could be very costly for supply
fleets.
But the Romans remedied this making the river
much more safer to sail on and also established
the first known Danubian fleet station in
Carnuntum.
This fleet was used to not only supply the
cities along the river but also to protect
the border, as the Danube was the border.
The Romans also brought wine making to the
region, established numerous bath houses,
and over all brought drastic economic development
to the area.
When it came to legions stationed in Pannonia
the amount and type of legions changed over
time but from the Hadrian era all the way
to late antiquity there were roughly 6 main
ones.
The 10th Legion Gemina stationed in Vindobona
todays Vienna
The 14th Legion Gemina stationed in Carnuntum
todays Petronell Carnuntum
The 1st Legion Adiutrix stationed in Brigetio
todays Komarom
The 2sc Legion Adiutrix stationed in Aquincum
today’s Budapest
The 4th Legion Flavia stationed in Singidunum
today’s Belgrade
And lastly
The 7th Legion Claudia stationed in Viminacium
As you may have noticed the area between Budapest
and Belgrade had a very large empty border
without any Legione protecting it.
This was mainly due to the very ineffective
way that legiones where assigned to various
Roman provinces but since its very boring
to talk about bureaucracy we can just conclude
that the Romans made a mistake.
Due to this mistake however the 2sc and 4th
legione had to protect a much larger border
then for example the 10th, 14th and 1st legiones.
This resulted in the fact that the Second
legione was by far the most active legion
in Pannonia having to go on many expeditionary
campaigns within and outside of the Roman
borders, to secure peace in the regione.
While this was happening the 4th legion was
always transferred to Budapest to protect
from any rear attacks.
This high activity of the Second legion in
Pannonia along with that fact that it was
stationed in today's Budapest where some of
the reasons why we decided to go with the
symbol of the second legion the pegasus for
our Project Pannonia colab.
The relative peace that was had by the Romans
in Pannonia was broken in 85.
This was because at this point the Dacian
kingdom which was fragment ever since the
death of Burebista finally united again and
started to hold raiding expeditions across
the Danube.
Most of these weren’t held in Pannonia but
in Moesia more south, however Pannonian legions
did play a vital role in this conflict.
The Romans eventually brokered a peace with
the Dacians but Romans being Romans knowing
this won't last started to built up many auxiliary
fortifications along the Danube, getting ready
for the eventual second war with the Dacians.
This war came in 101 ending with a Roman victory
in 102 but peace didn’t last as the third
Dacian war started in 105 with the Romans
again winning in 106 but this time they made
sure there won't be a 4th Dacian war.
They subdued the entire area and incorporated
in to the Roman Empire as a new province.
The Iazyges during this time where doing a
bit of flip flopping with their alliances
between the Dacians and Romans, however in
the end these wars resulted in a much more
direct control by the Romans over them, becoming
a client state between 117 and 123.
From there for about 50 plus years Pannonians
lived in relative peace, making wine, bathing,
socializing, trading, and whatever else the
Romans do.
However this all came to an end during the
outbreak of the Marcomannic Wars in 162.
These wars were the first signs of a large
scale migrations happening outside of the
Roman borders and many tribes that were already
living near the Roman border had nowhere to
go but across that border.
And so Panonnia got invaded first by Germanic
tribes from north and then by the Iazyges
from the east.
However these invasions managed to be repelled
by the Romans, after which the Romans launched
a counterattack against the Iazyges all while
yet another Germanic army crossed from the
north devastating Vienna and marching all
the way south to northern Italy before being
defeated.
After this the Romans undertook a large scale
offencive North which proved successful and
the Roman Emperor Marcu Aurelius even considered
creating buffer provinces north of Pannonia
to protect from any other future attacks,
but this did not happen as he died in 180
and his successor Commodus didn’t follow
through on these victories.
Commodus however did set out on another campaign
against Iazyges scoring a quick victory.
At this point it is safe to say that the Iazyges
where firmly under Roman control, however
what kind of control this was is unknown.
This combined with frequent small rebellions
and wars by the Iazyges throughout the next
century or so means that even though they
surely where controlled by the Romans the
area east of the Danube was never fully incorporated
in to the Empire as for example Dacia was.
However one argument against this could be
the fact that the construction of the Devil’s
Dyke started around the later half of the
second century probably used as part of the
Roman Limes.
Hence we can conclude the Romans did consider
this area as part of their Empire, even with
all the frequent Iazyges rebeliones.
After the Marcomannic wars the Pannonian area
became settled by a lot of Germanic people
that where either allowed to settle here or
used the confusion of the wars to cross the
border or even where the remnants of the defeated
Germanic armies.
These germanic settlers probably numbered
as much as the latin people living in it Pannonia
at this point.
However as it often does, during the next
couple of decades of “roughly” peace these
germanic people got slowly latinized just
as the Celts had before them.
The next major step in Roman Pannonian history
came during the Christianization of the Roman
Empire.
It seems that outside of Sirmium most of Pannonia
was very much starchly pagan until Constantine
came to power.
After which almost comically quickly the Pannonian
people, especially the higher class converted
to christianity, with pagan burials being
found increasingly rarely after early 4th
century.
It was also during Constantine's era that
the Vandals showed up on the fringes of the
Pannonian border being pushed their by the
Goths.
Constantine allowed the Vandals to settle
on the right bank of the Danube most likely
to control the troublesome Iazyges.
It was also at this point that the Devils
Dyke reached its highest extend meaning that
Romans were probably hoping to keep control
of the entire Pannonian plain for a while.
However all things must come to an end, and
the roughly 440 year long Roman control of
Pannonia was no different.
By the late Roman Period the border regions
had a constant activity of intertribal wars,
migrations, alliances, etc.
This combined with wavering internal Roman
politics meant that it was clear the Roman
hold on Pannonia wasn’t going to last.
There were several tribes like the Vandals,
Goths, etc. that attacked Pannonia in the
late 4th and early 5th century but the Romans
still managed to keep hold of the area until
the arrival of the Huns.
It is known that the Huns controlled much
of Pannonia by 437 but how and when exactly
did they conquered it is unknown but most
likely starting in around 420.
They probably did it the same way the Romans
conquered Pannonia well over 400 years earlier,
it was a gradual taking of control by the
Huns with interspersed Roman expeditions trying
to hold on to whatever they could.
It is also interesting to learn that the area
of specially southern Pannonia and Moesia
was given back and forth between the Western
and Eastern Roman Empires as both sides clearly
didn’t want to deal with the Hunnic raids.
The official Roman control of Pannonia is
dated to be until 447 when the Eastern Roman
empire finally gave up the claims to the Pannonian
lands but as we discussed, the Romans didn’t
really control the area for decades at this
point.
That is where I will conclude my video about
Roman pannonia because it’s time for Epimetheus
to take the torch and talk about the Huns.
Also check out the last video in the Project
Pannonia colab done by Historigraph who’s
talking about Hungarian involvement in WW2.
If you liked my videos please consider subscribing
and stick around for history.